this is how you make pandesal this  brings me back when I was a kid in the  Philippines and this is just the best  one thing about me is that I'm not a  huge fan of baking but it's 2023 new  year new me new struggles right  struggles for the lesson at least flour  salt sugar and our yeast give that a  good mix warm milk melted butter and one  egg  now we're just gonna mix the wet in the  dry they had a nice mix time to knead  clean counter some flour  okay Once the dough is smooth like this  lightly coat this in oil and cover in  plastic wrap now place this in a warm  area and we're going to let it rise  until it's double in size to release the  air cut it in half we are going to roll  them into logs  plain breadcrumbs  going to let this proof for another 10  to 15 minutes now we're just going to  bake them for about 10 to 15 minutes not  bad for my first time  exactly really good